>> IF YOU ARE TRAVELING 80 MILES
PER HOUR HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
YOU TO GO 80 MILES?
WHAT DO YOU THINK, CHELS?
>> I RUN A MILE IN 9 MINUTES.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE TIRING TURNING
THING?
DO YOU THINK THAT EFFECTS IT.
>> I AM GUESSING 400 TURNS IN A
MILE.
>> THAT IS GUESSING CALCULATION?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU WOULD
WORK THAT OUT.
IT HAS TO TAKE AT LEAST 15
MINUTES OR SOMETHING.
>> 15 MINUTES, PRETTY CLOSE.
>> HOW DID YOU GET THAT?
>> YOU CAN GUESSTIMATE IT.
>> I AM NOT GUESSTIMATING.
I AM USING MATH AND SCIENCE.
>> DON'T SIT THERE AND JUDGE
HER, SHE WAS SMART ENOUGH TO GET
A MAN THAT KNEW THE ANSWER TO
MARRY HER.
AFTER WATCHING THIS VIDEO, I
HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS, PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME CHELSEA AND
TRAVIS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> HOW HAVE YOU BEEN DOING?
>> WE HAVE DONE BETTER.
>> ARE YOU MAD AT TRAVIS FOR
PUTTING THAT ON LINE?
>> HONESTLY, I WAS TICKED.
I AM OKAY NOW.
>> TRAVIS, DO YOU CONSIDER YOUR
WIFE SMART?
>> SHE FLUNKED OUT OF COLLEGE.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
SAY MIDDLE SCHOOL.
>> TRAVIS, DO YOU FANTASIZE
ABOUT HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
OTHER WOMEN?
>> ACTUALLY, HAVEN'T.
>> MAYBE YOU SHOULD MAKE A SEX
TAPE.
THAT WILL PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT
THE OTHER TAPE.
>> NO.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> I AM SURE YOU ARE AN
INTELLIGENT WOMAN, CHELSEA.
YOU KNOW WHAT MILES PER HOUR
MEANS, RIGHT?
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
>> I DON'T WANT A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
>> WHAT IS FASTER A CHEETAH
GOING 70 MILES PER HOUR OR A
CAR?
>> I WOULD SAY BOTH.
[LAUGHTER] I AM GOING TO HAVE
YOU GIVE YOU PARTIAL CREDIT.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU KNOW
MORE ABOUT THAN YOUR HUSBAND?
>> KIDS.
>> SHE'LL COACH ME THROUGH
TALKING TO KIDS.
SHE IS STRONG.
I AM NOT SMART WITH AT ALL.
>> SHOCKING SHE WOULD HAVE SO
MUCH IN COMMON WITH FIVE YEAR
OLDS.
[LAUGHTER].
WHAT IS YOUR EXCUSE FOR THAT
VIDEO?
>> LET'S JUST SAY THAT WHOLE
TIME WE HAD JUST FINISHED FINALS
AT SCHOOL.
WE WERE BOTH SUPER TIRED.
I WAS TO TIRED.
WE WERE TRAVELING AND I DON'T
LIKE CARS.
>> THAT MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
[LAUGHTER].
HAVE PEOPLE BEEN MAKING MEAN
COMMENTS? >> I AM THE WORLD'S
WORST HUSBAND RIGHT NOW ON THE
INTERNET.
>> ALL ABOUT PERSPECTIVE.
THINK ABOUT KOBE AND HIS WIFE.
>> A FEW YEARS AGO HE RAPE ADD
WOMAN.
>> I KNOW ABOUT THAT.
THAT WASN'T HIS WIFE.
OH I SEE WHAT YOU ARE SAYING>>
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO SAY?
>> I WISH I WOULDN'T HAVE POSTED
IT.
I FEEL BAD.
PUT HER THROUGH A LOT THE LAST
FEW DAYS.
WE DEFINITELY WEREN'T LOOKING TO
BE FAMOUS.
>> IF WE CAN LEARN ANYTHING FROM
THIS VIDEO, MAKE SURE YOU GIVE
THE WOMEN YOU ARE